bienvenue dans pas fait comment on a
énormément de sujets à traiter on va
aller très vite on va parler
naturellement d'air france on va parler
aussi de nadine morano et de michel
platini qui sont au centre de
l'actualité et pour en parler stéphane
minson bonjourbonjour patrice de
l'université de versailles-saint-quentin
toujours professeur de droit public
toujours d'abord félicité mme nicole
bonjour bonjour ça va bien sinon oui je
vais passer une bonne quinzaine bonne
semaine mais plutôt agréable vous étiez
la nouvelle venue mais y'a plus nouveau
coup un joli c'est laurent garin bonjour
bonjour vous êtes dit frère vous êtes
libre à la livrée du canal à deux pas
d'ici là deux palissy donc si vous
n'êtes pas venus de très loin d'eux
n'est pas fatigués nous être en pleine
forme et on va pouvoir pouvoir parler
avec vous de tous les vices bettana
alexis 1010 beach
1 qu'est le prix nobel de littérature
prix nobel de littérature que je crois
que vous avez lu aussi florence mercadé
choqué bonjour bonjour toujours avocate
au barreau de versailles toujours il
jean charles lajoie dit bonjour aux
éditeurs peut-être un bon 8 pourquoi on
n'irait pas au bout puisque vous êtes
généralement les prix nobel de
littérature quand ils arrivent comme nom
arrive tout le monde est effrayé parce
que personne ne les a jamais lui sauf
l'année derni
évidemment ce qui rassure ans pour fleur
pellerin personne ne sait pas c'est pas
honteux c'est de la palud c'est pas une
bonne nouvelle en tout cas pour poutine
visiblement ça près de votre de
littérature vous est inconnu en france
parce qu'elle est une médicis de l'essai
en 2013 vrai que ce n'est pas une
inconnue pour nous enfin la fin de
l'homme rouge était quand même
traitement qu'à l'époque qui avait quand
même marqué l'année 2013 donc non c'est
cette fois ci on connaissait un peu
quand même avant de découvrir son alors
elle a une technique de travail assez
particulière qui est de prendre beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de renseignements et
de témoignages et de faire des petits
récits tout cet été ses commentaires et
ses tranches de vie en fait qu'elle va
prendre l appui qu un peu partout dans
la population
le robot vous vous continuez à la fin de
l'homme en rouge ouais pour ma part oui
c'est 5,4 et qui est très lisible que
c'est un cas très bien écrit vraiment qu
est accessible et très bien fait je n'ai
pas rajouté dans chaque cellule avant
oui tout à fait
les unités 1
la patte si les jeunes je reconnais que
je n'ai jamais lu encore d'accord donc
je ne sais pas je me suis fait confiance
et je vais lire je vais me procurer vous
la fin de la fin de l'homme rouge
notamment enfin quelques étincelles
ses romans les plus connus et qui donne
quand je disais c'est pas une très bonne
nouvelle pour poutine
c'est vrai que c'est une clean des
critiques fortes du du régime actuel et
qu'elle considère comme n'ayant rien à
envier aux dards d'autrefois ou du moins
où a lieu au dirigeant de l'urss
d'autrefois
je le dis on sent pas poutine vaciller
sur ses bases depuis ce matin non plus
donc on n'est pas super inquiet pour
poutine à cause de sa super à qui on
sait aussi que le prix de bella la rue
devant des ddd roland aussi politique
enfin il ya derrière derrière les choix
parfois aussi des shows politiques
nobel décerné au chinois a rien changé
en chine
voilà c'est un coup d'éclairage qu'il
était indispensable et qui est vraiment
très bien qu'il faut saluer et apprécié
mais c'est vrai que je pense pas que
poutine soit particulièrement embêter
aujourd'hui non mais je voudrais que ça
ça en effet cette couronne ou quelqu'un
qui était plutôt opposés à poutine d
sais pas s'il ya beaucoup font qu'ils
n'ont qui parle comme ça mais je sais
que vous allez maurice et où habite tél
on vient de rossi qui viennent en russie
je crois toujours que je vois qu'il est
toujours là dû s'exiler
c'est lui le patron de l'un d'eux le
président biélorusse lui envoyer un
message de sincères félicitations
alors que l l'assassinant permanent
meilleure équipe et qu'il a interdit ces
bouquins en biélorussie prochaine
pourrait dire qu'au quotidien c'est
alignant d'avoir les pieds en suède et
il a il a interdit on trouve aucun de
ses livres en bélarus et lui envoie ce
matin un truc quand on souffre et
lisible sincèrement on est sincèrement
c'est sympa régal doré parce que brive
ligne en profiteront la petite anecdote
c'est que son éditeur français a publié
en livre l'info son dernier roman il ya
trois jours avant son prix nobel savoir
vivre et et l'avenir car c'est là ces
actes sud livre est arrivé il ya trois
jours en librairie et prix nobel et où
manière dont l acer s'attend qu'il est
un très nombreux vous avez pas un livre
de michel platini
non pas encore quant au corps qui veut
parler michel platini qui rattrape et
semble-t-il pas par les affaires on
s'est passé c'est une affaire dans
laquelle il a trempé aussi c'est une
affaire qui était lancée comme une boule
puante
mais en tout cas sa candidature est
plombé sa part est un peu un peu
compromis parce que c'est c'est vrai
quel que soit enfin après je pense que
florence
nous tes fans ne donne pas plus
amplement juridique manavit bien bien
bien éclairant sûrement mais c'est vrai
que c'est quand même curieux d'avoir
accepté cette somme qui est quand même
assez astronomiques passant par le prêt
de 2 millions d'euros versés après des
années après que le boulot est effectué
dans des conditions le boulot n'a pas
réussi certes on fait ce qu'il devait il
devait battre il devait trouver un
accord entre tous les calendriers de
tout un continent sur le football ce qui
est absolument impossible donc ya pas
réussi voilà d'où les mamans l'essayer
mais moi de le commentaire que ça apaise
le truc c'est le l'esprit de bande et
qui est sûrement très sympathique quand
on bénéficie
mais en france était un peu jusqu'à en
tout cas jusqu'à avant-hier platini
intouchable quand on a commencé à
s'attaquer à lui enfin quand cette
affaire est tombé tout le monde et s'est
précipité d'un mais c'est pas possible
c'est un c'est un saint il est c'est
extraordinaire manuel valls ou d'une
rapidité le plus vif l'éclair ses
possibilités pour dire qui est gardé sa
confiance
il avait invité voir à barcelone nord
est mais avant même de savoir enfin
c'est une exagération ce qui est sûr
c'est qu'il est plus soutenue en france
avaient probablement que dans les autres
pays
fédération allemande notamment c'est
vrai que c'est le président de l'uefa
après temps après je me soucie pas en
tout je ne suis pas entre en tout cas au
courant du dessous des choses mais c'est
vrai que c'est à l'évidence un peu
dommage pour la france que c'était un
candidat bien c'est bien qu'un français
avec sadc ou de fonction etc
et là ça passe j'ai pas fini encore
assez pour le pays c'est franchement
dommage il fait à peine en plus il a
fait appel n'est pas suspensif je veux
dire qu'il continue à être suspendu et
la commission peut prolonger de 45 jours
encore les fameux 90 jours mais pour
autant on arrivera quand même avant le
26 février jusqu'à la date de nomination
du futur président c'est le 26 février
quand bien même il
voilà il prolonge de 45 jours il
pourrait quand même se présenter mais je
trouve c'est un petit peu plombé ça
dépend si ici on en sait un peu plus sur
les réseaux de pour lesquelles il est
souvent dit parce que l'egypte a dit
peut-être blanc comme neige dans cette
affaire non c'est non on peut supposer
pardon mais on peut supposer aussi que
c'est une boule puante envoyé par
blatter en représailles de la
candidature de platini compte en 2010 3
le mont blanc que lui il ya une
maladresse qui qui qui va le
d'entacher parce que l'argent il existe
donc prendre de l'argent comme ça enfin
recevoir de l'argent d'une façon aussi
désinvolte et curieuse c'est vrai que ça
ça ne donne pas du personnage une image
de nous de rectitude ou de capacité à
gérer un truc aussi énorme que la
fédération internationale de foot voir
c'est de toute façon il y aura des
dommages collatéraux dans les petits
sujets pour continuer non vous allez
acheter quelque chose je voulais non vie
peut-être juste un petit point c'est que
la commission électorale qui va valider
les candidatures le sont le fait après
avis de la commission d'éthique
commission d'éthique qui vient de
s'ouvrir pendant donc c'est un peu voilà
et après il ya le tribunal arbritral
rail a aussi d'autres d'autres recours
possible au rabot va pas entrer dans les
détails dans les petits sujets je sais
pas si vous avez vu ce sondage les
français ont le sentiment que leur
pouvoir d'achat
mels et vous permet entre autres oui
c'est toujours le vécu et la réalité qui
sont difficiles c'est comme la sécurité
voilà par rapport à la notion d'ordre
public et est ce que vivent en nous un
sentiment d'insécurité pas une grogne
qui vous dira non je me sens
parfaitement sécurité ça la baisse du
pouvoir d'achat tout le monde a
l'impression que je ne sais pas si c'est
une réalité objective en revanche
et puis ça dépend des catégories
socioprofessionnelles des catégories
sociales je vous ai déçus assure
personnes âgées personnes mais je crois
savoir que sur une moyenne qui doit
s'échelonner a omis zou je crois moins
dix ou quinze ans je crois qu'il est
temps mais c'est vrai que ça se voit pas
beaucoup parce que tellement de
redistribution que les mails et les les
écarts sont très faibles en fait elle
concerne non seulement pas beaucoup et
quand ça baisse ça à baisser en 2013
mais de 0,1 ça peut monter de très peu
donc on peut avoir aussi une impression
de stagnation qui fait qu'ils donnent
peut-être un sentiment de baisse sauf
absolument oui vous savez que le il ya
un peu près plus de temps aux environs
de 50 % du pib qui est redistribuée
et que d'autre part les examens une
redistribution énorme absolument et que
les écarts avant redistribution
notamment fiscales sont de 1,8 et après
redistribution sont environ de 1 à 3
effectivement un effet redistributif
d'autres sociétés d'un choix de société
qui est assez fort avec ça c'est vrai un
mot là-dessus non pas ce qu'est ce qu'il
ya c'est que c'est sûrement aussi parce
que on est tous entourés enfin on
connaît tous forcément hélas une ou deux
personnes au chômage donc je pense que
le sentiment de baisse de pouvoir
d'achat etc
elle est aussi liée à sa suite le
sentiment d'insécurité raser ou de
connaître quelqu'un qui est dont les
revenus ont été divisés par 2 ou non est
revenue en quasiment disparu sûr que
même si à titre personnel on n'a pas une
baisse de revenus on peut on s'imaginer
on se retrouve plongé dans un univers où
là on s'en ressent une baisse de pouvoir
d'achat je pense que c'est ça aussi y
avait moins de moins de 5 millions de
chômeurs
encore plus oui un pays à la wii le fait
ce qui arrive aux autres fonds ne fait
pas au houga partir du moment où on est
obligé de compter bien sûr qu'on va
sentir le poids du prix des choses quand
on est dispensé de ça on s'en rend moins
compte quand on fera ça revient évidence
laurent pardon servat question tout à
fait à m avoir une librairie aujourd'hui
c'est compliqué c'est très compliqué
mais voilà je pense que c'est plus la
passion qui mène le débat qu'autre chose
brecko nicholas mee commenté brésil raus
libre a livré une grosse structure on
est quatorze libraire 14
pourquoi il ya un peu de monde mais
voilà économiquement ce n'est pas le
métier plus rentables qui soit en centre
ville
mais malgré ça je pense que
le fait qu'on apporte un plus aux gens
pas que ce soit un bien culturel fait
quand même que ça fait bouger les gens
enfin ils ont fait bouger les libraires
et ça voilà la rémunération n'est pas au
niveau de ce qu'on souhaiterait bien sûr
mais voilà ça reste ça reste ça reste
indispensable mais c'est vrai que c'est
très compliqué à faire vivre et je pense
que de toute façon les petites
librairies depuis vocation
malheureusement à pouvoir rester en
centre ville du fait de délais à l'abri
de ce genre de crise les petites
structures en fait on est en location
dans pardon alors c'est un peu en dehors
de l'émission bye on voit que les
grosses structures comme la fnac et ont
des difficultés non mais ça c'est très
très grosses structures qui étaient des
concurrents
j'étais de ton corps et l'assedic de la
librairie maintenant la concurrence elle
vaut bien qu internet la concurrence
vient d'internet alors aussi un peu des
supermarchés
enfin ça deviens voilà mais les très
grosses structures se sont peut-être
aussi perdu dans la diversification
ils ont tellement ouvert l'offre qu'ils
pouvaient
mettre en place dans leurs magasins qui
se sont peut-être un père un peu perdus
un an mais aujourd'hui en tout cas la
librairie indépendante 2 centre-ville
fonctionne bien donc c'est un commerce
mal acquis en france
ça tombe bien la librairie indépendante
cei probablement une perte de pouvoir
d'achat depuis qu'elle ya quelques
années mais oui c'est sûr même base est
simple mais ça fonctionne alors j'ai un
cadeau pour vous puisque dans le cadeau
de bienvenue c'est quelque chose dont on
a le secret ici c'est le micro trottoir
on adore et donc on va commencer mais la
réalité sociale parce qu'il passe à la
mouvance vous en avez vécu quand même
présenté comme un cadeau personnel
alors là c'est un cadeau pour le regard
1 donc c'est un micro trottoir sur le
climat social puis après on va parler de
d'air france notamment et jean sont
moroses et c
on sait pas trop 20 au nouveau climat
social que ce soit toutes entreprises
confondues finalement elle à lui et et
bure gelagri lance moment un bon pas bon
que son gouvernement compte qu'ils
peuvent enfin ils font pas tout avec
tout ce qui se passe
les migrants nadine morano
enfin etc etc tout ça je trouve que
c'est déplorable votre la france sur
métal les français se remettent en cause
aussi soit qu'il ya beaucoup à faire
c'est particulièrement détestable et ben
faut rester optimiste experts et que ça
ira mieux
voilà il faut espérer que ça ira mieux
il ya une conclusion philosophique dont
on avait besoin on va parler de air
france de la situation d'air france
alors évidemment tout le monde a été
appris par ces images de ce drh qui
sautent les grilles qui garde quand même
précieusement et son ipad et sa cravate
un il a peur de la vie elle mais elle a
quand même une favela cravate tout le
monde alors a dit évidemment violence
intolérable mais voilà on peut toujours
poser la question où est ce qu'est la
vraie violence est ce que c'est la
violence ddd syndicale déviance qu'on a
vu comme ça de ce contre 7 e rh est ce
que c'est la violence des dés de la
direction du dialogue social qui dit où
vous acceptez nos mesure où les c6 nice
en citrouille personnes oui la vraie
violence
rien rien ne peut qu il garde une est
partout d'ailleurs arrivé rien ne peut
excuser donc en france en 2015 qu'on
s'en prenne physiquement à 2-2 drh
quelles que soient les qualités des
fautes et de drh va c'est une heure de
gens surexcités enfin je veux dire ça
donne une image absolument
catastrophique et du syndicalisme et de
et des employés les ouvriers assez
lamentable après bien évidemment je veux
pas défendre cette agression je trouve
monstrueuse mais on peut aussi se dire
légitimement que pour qu'on en arrive
pour que les syndicalistes et pour que
l'équipe arrive à s'en prendre comme ça
avec cette violence à ces deux de drh
c'est que les annonces ont peut-être été
fait avec une certaine brutalité
peut-être un peu de mépris peut-être
voilà derrière il n'ya jamais de fumée
sans feu de la phrase est vraiment
idiote mais je pense que voilà c'est ça
n'arrive pas tout le temps et
heureusement et si ça arrive c'est qu'à
un moment il ya des choses calcul qui
ont dû fonctionner très très mal il a
vécu ce symbole qu'ils ont attaqué
françois des personnes ont proprement
parler après voilà c'est ça reste il
était représentant de l'entreprise et en
face d'eux il y avait des gens qui
étaient peut-être pas non plus
représentatif de tous les syndicats et
qui représentait peut-être finalement
que même voilà c'est ça
ils ont identifié ils sont en train de
remonter sur le fait que c'était
prémédité
parce qu'ils ont un plan d'attaqué ils
ont arraché les caméras enfin ils ont
fait un certain nombre de choses donc
c'est pas quelque chose de spontané
c'est quelque chose de prémédité je
pense qu on est donc dans dans une
action qui est un trouble troubles
publics pour pour faire de la com pour
attirer d'accord pour attirer
l'attention parce que moi je pense à mon
pape aborde comme pour bah oui je suis
parfaitement d'accord mais ils sont
peut-être trompés puisque là ils ont ils
ont à peu près tout le monde contre eux
sur ce type d'exactions
mais moi je pense que dire est-ce qu'on
peut comparer ces deux violence je suis
pas du tout d'accord par jeu
la question de choc parce que le droit
je vois là ça me choque parce que là de
cette violence physique est absolument
scandaleuse et qui est unique parce que
quand on a vu quand vous voyez par
exemple vous dire tout ce qui s'est
passé sur le terrain on veut dire il ya
eu des attaques dans dix ans on brûle
des voitures ils ont brûlé des pneus il
sort son brio forces de l'ordre mais
jamais ils se sont attaqués dans le cade
en plus une réunion d'un cce enfin ils
se sont jamais attaqués à la direction
en tant que tel qui est juste là pour en
train d'essayer de négocier et on peut
absolument pas légitimé par le fait
qu'on licencie de 1900 personnes enfin
ou licencient il ya un plan de
restructuration qui fait que peut-être
de 1900 personnes seront
affecté peu digitimes et de telles
actions aussi violentes et moi je trais
moment est-ce que c'était pas
extrêmement violent aussi oui démarrage
de dialogue ceci nous sommes lancés 2009
sans licenciement fin c'est comme ça
qu'on présente pas comme ça que ça se
passe c'était peut-être une façon de
présenter qui est peut-être pas très
long mais deux de demain demain on peut
couper la tête du drh williams est au
bout d'une pique on dire bah oui bavure
c'est un type face à 2900 je me suis
tout à fait de l'avis de florence cesser
cette violence et quel que soit encore
une fois les maladresses possible et
surprennent probable de la direction et
des syndicats pour arriver à ne plus
pouvoir parler on peut pas accepter
l'idée qu'on s'en fait les images opus
sont extrêmement humiliante c'est à dire
que quand on voit qu'on voit ce type à
moitié nue qui escaladent le
la grille aidés par les vigiles avec les
polices fait de deux côtés bête traquée
on sent que le titre si janot est
complètement mais c'est très très
exceptionnelle comme comme l'événement
ce parce que le dialogue social se passe
pas comme ça y est c'est pas le même ces
cas là bas c'est l'arbre qui cache les
gens cherchent à joigny sur la ligne de
manuel valls et de françois hollande il
faut remarquer féliciter ils se sont
senties quand même méprisé totalement il
ya cette femme là dont la vidéo passe
partout qui explique à plusieurs
reprises qu'ils essaient d'attirer
l'attention des désirs directeur qui ne
réagissaient absolument pas qui expliqué
qu'ils se sentaient pas écouté du tout
juste rien ne justifie cette violence
mais c'est de ce sont des gens qui
finalement était désespérée quoi et
qu'il ait besoin d'être entendu et de
cette façon là maintenant on en parle
partout
donc on espère qu'on va pouvoir les
enfants n'en parle pas dans leur sens
bien entendu mais je pense qu'ils
étaient prêts à tout c'est il ya
d'autres justifie pas mais je sais pas
si vous avez vu cette vidéo la de cette
femme là elle s'adresse a eu à plusieurs
reprises et les dirigeants ne réagissent
pas dans une salle de réunion dans des
discussions avec des syndicats parce que
c'est peut-être un autre problème qu'on
a vu au bras après c'est que est ce que
la direction d'air france n'aurait pas
dû agir depuis un peu plus longtemps
mais sûr sûr sûr ce dialogue cette
absence de dialogue et je veux je croit
savoir qu'air france n'est pas
l'entreprise la grande entreprise la
plus réputée pour la qualité de dialogue
social quelques horizons qu'ils ont des
procès ont ils des années et des années
on en appelle à chaque fois vous l'aurez
remarqué à l'état qui règle le dis à ces
médias tchèques à hauteur de 17%
tout tend parfois critiquant son action
ça montre qu'on à grand peine à se
défaire justement de la dette étatique
et puis d'autre part moi je crois que je
pense en effet que la violence sociale
et la violence physique la violence
sociale que représente ces plans de
licenciements massifs etc et la violence
physique ne sont pas ne peuvent pas être
mises sur le même plan sont de deux
registres de d'expression si j'ose dire
différents et puis enfin je j'ai lu je
ne sais plus quand dans la grande presse
que je suis passé mélenchon lui même ou
ou quelqu'un de proche de lui qui
comparaît ce mouvement de foule au
tableau de delacroix vous savez la
liberté des peuples au sujet la
révolution de 1830
c'est une foule c'est pas le peuple jeu
il faut pas faire cette confusion là il
s'agissait d'une foule d'une foule en
rage alors avec ses vrais directement
devrait méditer mais c'est pas c'est pas
le peuple qu'il faut pas mélanger
mélangez une chose est ce que justement
enfin on arrivait à la il ya évidemment
la situation d'air france parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de compagnies au fond qu aux
disparus ils servent à rien à d'autres
paname enfin iliad et des compagnies
cause disparu air france on ne sait pas
si elle est condamnée ou pas mais on a
l'impression que les bonnes décisions
n'ont pas été prises au bon moment qu'on
a repoussés reposer repoussé qu'on
arrive à des décisions un peu extrêmes
se met déjà en 1994 avait eu déjà des
plans de réorganisation qu'ils ont fait
marche arrière
mais le problème chez air france pour
ses con à un syndicat qu'il semelle qui
est majoritaire qui peut signer pour la
totalité des salariés d'air france et
pas que pour les pilotes de ligne
puisque le syndicat des pilotes de ligne
qui est un syndicat complètement
autonome
un peu comme le syndicat de journalistes
d'ailleurs keep affilié ni à la cgt 9 dt
ha et qui peut bloquer un peu un peu
tout le système et le gros problème de
la france c'est le mode de rémunération
des pilotes
les pilotes chez klm ou autres ils sont
payé avec un salaire forfaitaire
mensuelle pour les pilotes d'air france
50% de la rémunération est basée sur les
heures de vol
donc violent pas heureuse ils ont moins
de rémunération en période haute ils ont
une rémunération
cela remet donc ça fait des charges très
importantes et il ya un problème de
discussion et la discussion qui bloque
avec les pilotes c'est aussi sur la
façon dont on reconsidère les conditions
de travail et les conditions de
rémunération et donc c'est ça qui
block et du coup on bascule sur un plan
de réorganisation beaucoup plus général
puisqu'ils ont claqué la porte la
semaine dernière mais en gros stylo je
sers france coûte 20% plus cher que la
concurrence ça c'est vrai que c'est
compliqué ce qui est compliqué aussi
pour air france et que les compagnies
low cost de son moins en moins cher et
le service est de pire en pire faut le
reconnaître
comment ça c'est un autre débat non sur
les construit et parallèlement fait un
peu pendant qu'ils attirent beaucoup oui
mais après c'est assez lamentable
enfin le pdg de ryanair il était en
train de proposer à ses pilotes de ce1
ce2 s'inscrire comme auto entrepreneur
est en irlande pour les payer en
factures
je sais que c'est difficile pour air
france de lutter contre ça et de l'autre
côté de la balance ya les compagnies
innovatrices golf du golfe qui soupait
elle a été carrément tout le monde avec
ton pas du tout les mêmes charges et
cetera qui peut que n'ont pas les mêmes
droits d'aéroport enfin donc air france
joue avec les dés pipés
donc il ya même eu une négociation qui a
permis aux compagnies du golfe devenir
plus contre la baule dans la vente des
rafale
on nous on aura une couleur ou
audelignes enfin je dis que c'est très
difficile alors après peut-être que ça
pourrait être mieux se préparer à
l'arrivée des low cost
on a l'impression que les directions
papa le dire qu actuellement les
directions successives de la france ont
un peu attendu d'être confronté d'être
au pied du mur ce plaisir pour pau pour
prendre des mesures alors que l'on
pouvait penser dans que le commerce du
voyage
et rien n'est changé qu'on m'appelle
considérablement on pouvait on pouvait
aussi faire une réflexion intelligente
aussi un moment de se dire il a parlé
gens qui ont vraiment pas un rond les
étudiants etc
il ya peut-être des gens qui seront pas
tentés par le fait de voyager dans des
avions où l'hôtesse de l'air fait la
femme de ménage des toits des toilettes
et poussettes le réacteur avec un pilote
qui travaillent trois fois plus que les
eaux avec une la totalité du truc paye
enfin je veux dire c'étaient des
conditions je reconnais moi je vais à la
place du pdg d'air france je me serais
planté par et j'aurais dit mais non les
français sont pas suffisamment saut pour
pour se lancer là dedans dès de cette
espèce de course vers la fausse gratuité
va vers le voyage merdique vers les
conditions terribles on pouvait imaginer
qu'il ya une sorte de tout peut-être de
le tourner avions qui volent
qu'aujourd'hui un mandat de six ans et
découvrir des petites une même société
il fait pas rêver on voit que
l'ouverture l'ouverture du ciel à la
concurrence qu'on a connu au cours de
ces dernières décennies a les ailes et
vous le disiez un peu un peu pipés parce
que il ya quand même encore des enjeux
de souveraineté les étals n'abandonne
pas quand ça marche et leurs compagnies
aériennes respectives et on voit que
même il ya une espèce d'effet de loupe
qu'est ce que c'est qu'un actionnaire à
17 % ça n'est rien mais ce n'est pas
n'importe lequel c'est l'état donc on
continue encore à en appeler à sa
médiation mais l'état a encore son mot à
dire y compris dans le fonctionnement de
l'établissement aéroports de paris enfin
on voit qu'il ya aussi ce que la
compagnie paille à l'aéroboxe est
vraiment aimé qui revient à l'état
lui-même et rita dont constitue un
marché mais ouvert à la concurrence mais
on voit que c'est même une espèce
d'entre-deux assez délicat à saisir
quand même nom en rien à ce que vous
disiez moi j'ai pris ces avions qui
coûtent pas cher du tout et
effectivement dans lesquels tout est
payant
nourriture etc mais j'avais peut-être
pas les moyens de me permets prendre un
but
non mais c'est vrai même des
installations je fait normal quand on
n'a pas d'argent on essaye de payer le
moins cher possible
ce que je trouve scandaleux c'est quand
on a de l'argent vous voyez juste ces
compagnies comme je trouve scandaleux
c'est à dire quoi chacun sa façon de
fonctionnement qui est différent depuis
l'euro par mois et qu'on voit des gens
qui étaient une divine euros par mois
qui voyagent sur ryanair ou sur easyjet
surtout qu'ils sont d'anarchie c'est un
scandale social passe un sondage
effectué elle parce que ils sont en
train de tuer l'économie réalisation de
la consommation mais oui ils sont en
particulier tenais mon jeu c'est comme
s'ils se taper l'hôtesse gratuitement
mais vous allez le ghost d'avions 'tout
le monde fr ses voyages et ses moyens si
on en met les moyens points d'accord
toujours alors donc il faut pas quand on
a de l'argent non je t'assure que nous a
ajouté cette taxe aussi écologique a été
imposé par y
c'est là que la france qui est frais qui
sont impose sa rivale était un peu temps
d'en discuter et qu'il n'y ait plus que
la france uniquement qu'ils soient
redevables de cette taxe coup et voilà
donc qui me les sauver après le monde
entier mais ça peut être un moment de
lancer ce débat et d'ouvrir un peu que
la france
alors ça pose quand même la question du
dialogue social en france on a
l'impression que ce dialogue social et
ip qu'il est difficile qui autant en
allemagne on connaît la cogestion là où
la force des syndicats
les négociations à l'intérieur des
branches et des entreprises autant en
france c'est l'air très compliqué qu'à
des basses et comme ce que ça exige que
les questions sociales
bien sûr que c'est dans les tpe dialogue
social il est là tous les jours tous les
jours quand on a certes 8 2 3 salariés
du dialogue social il est là tous les
jours je sais pas si vous laurent vous
faites du dialogue social mais votre
librairie tous les jours et dans les
grandes entreprises il ya du dialogue
social et ça se passe c'est plus
compliqué parce qu'elle est lourde
heures et on attend les décrets
d'application de la loi rebsamen qui va
essayer d'alléger un peu toutes ces
couches d'obligations de négociation
d'accords il ya 17
il est aujourd'hui les drh doivent
mettre en place dix sept négociations
par an avec les partenaires sociaux donc
c'est énorme
donc il est de regrouper un peu donc
c'est ça qui m'a indiqué mais si on
essaye d'assainir un peu de simplifier
de fluidifier je pense que ça se passe
plutôt pas si mal que ça en battant mal
que sa soeur de faiblesse endémique des
syndicats et diallo radicalisation mais
s'invite il se radicalise parce qu'ils
sont faits voilà peut-être je veux pas
faire un aussi se radicalise parce
qu'ils sont faibles parce que ça rend
pas les choses de sens ça rend pas les
choses plus simples mais il n'ya pas que
les sociétés avec lesquelles on négocie
en négocier que les délégués du
personnel comité d'entreprise avec le
comité d'hygiène et de sécurité dans
lequel il peut avoir zéro syndicats moi
j'ai des tas de clients qui ont des
entreprises de dti de 700 ou 800 séries
il ya même pas de syndicat il ya juste
d'une personne ce syndicat pas de
syndicat et on discute avec les avec les
partenaires sociaux naturelles qui sont
les élus du cce où les délégués du
personnel et et on arrive à faire des
accords et il ya des possibilités de
faire des accords maintenant la loi est
beaucoup plus souple et la loi rebsamen
va assouplir encore les choses donc moi
je suis pas négatif comme ça oui
négative sur les relations avec les
syndicats qui se radicalise parce qu'ils
sont faibles il faudrait qu'il se
remette en question
et puis parce qu'ils vieillissent sont
finalement les syndicats que je crois
c'est ce que j'ai dans mes dossiers qui
qui accompagne les salariés dans des
contentieux prud'homaux sont des gens
j'ai encore qu'on croise est un il est à
80 ans il à venir j'ai peut-être
m'arrêter thème temps mais ils
n'arrivent pas à recruter des jeunes
parce que les jeux ne sont pas motivés
ont pas envie de dire
oui une faiblesse le faiblesse de
recrutement mais quitte à qui et on doit
faire ou alors est ce qu est ce que la
spécialisation jean luc malet qu'il faut
il faut dire que nicolas sarkozy faut en
finir avec les corps intermédiaires non
non non faut pas finir moi je pense
qu'il faut qu'ils se professionnalise il
faut également faire oui mais là ils
représentent rien on peu très peu comme
dans le privé pratiquement rien et et on
voit bien quand il ya eu un vote par
exemple se fera au monde et voilà qui
est ce que voulait travailler le
dimanche 96 % des salariés
c'est le soir le soir dont le soir 80
s'ajustant dd oui disent oui si les
syndicats noureddine on a bavardé 164
soit pas loupé qu'est-ce qu'on fait avec
ça
c'est donc un idéal ils ont pas le le
syndicalisme de participation et
réformistes de l'allemagne parce que
souvent nous dans l'histoire des 30 40
dernières années
je le regardais la la surpuissance d'un
syndicat comme il des metal syndicat des
industries qui a quand même à plusieurs
reprises parvenus à faire plier les
gouvernements souvenons nous il ya
quelques mois mais de la grèce
la grève des pilotes a failli de la
lufthansa rsa ne sont pas enfin ce ne
sont pas des tendres
là c'est pas des tendres non mais ils
ont du pouvoir la résidence voilà ils
ont un énorme pouvoir mais qui conduit
parfois au conflit qui ne lui qu'elle
manquerait pas jourdren ne valent
toujours par le par le dialogue et non
dans vos avez raison mais mais ils sont
très forts ils ont ils représentent
présent leurs salariés ne serait ce que
parce que je crois que pour avoir
bénéficié d accord il faut être
syndiqués exactement il les a une
culture post post 45 assez particulière
en allemagne on observe exactement la
même le même phénomène pour les partis
politiques
vous avez vous n'avez jamais eu en
france de parti politique de masse de
vraies politiques parti politique de
masse alors à l'exception peut-être du
gaullisme à certains moments alors qu'en
allemagne
un parti comme le spd par exemple pour
prendre l'un des plus anciens a toujours
été un très grand parti avec plusieurs
centaines de milliers voire millions
d'adhérents s'est mise en culture du
parti effectivement ils ont eu parfois
ça marche
le bidon je voulais juste dire aussi que
leslie les délégués syndicaux sont
beaucoup dans encore dans la lutte des
classes alors que les salariés ne sont
plus je pense dans les entreprises dans
la lutte des classes et on peut
peut-être croisé par rapport aux
sondages dont vous vouliez parler je
crois patrice sur le fait que les
français et à la réforme et la
libéralisation
donc on a des gens qui sont qu'il
s'agisse d'économie parce qu'on parle
d'économie depuis deux ans beaucoup on
parle beaucoup d'économies donc les gens
commencent à intégrer l'économie avancé
ils vont vers de la libéralisation
alors qu'on a des syndicats qui sont
encore beaucoup dans la lutte des
classes et il ya un décrochage de
compréhension je pense entre eux et
c'est pour ça que quand sarkozy dit
voilà lé corps intermédiaires sont en
crise il peut pas lui vous avez quand
même tout à fait en avant dans mon
ancienne vie donc d'industrial allait
rater mais forcément là il y avait des
rayés les syndicats l'anglais y avait du
syndicat très fort et très présent et
c'est sûr qu'il reste encore dans la vie
des classes ferment en quoi c'est encore
ce modèle là qu'ils ont ils sont assez
fort encore dans le service public oui
ils sont encore très très fort mais
les compromis sont pas partis en fait de
leur chemin en vacances quoi et c'est
vrai que c'est un peu compliqué sur pour
faire avancer les choses quoi mais je
voulais enfin moi ce qui m'étonne quand
même c'est l'éclairage que là on a donné
au syndicalisme on l'a pas donnée sur la
violence qui a eu avec les taxis il ya
une vraie violence aussi tandis que là
les syndicalistes ont fait la une du
wall street journal
je pense pas que les taxis parisiens ont
fait la une d'un journal anglais ou
américains quoi s'est passé ça brille ça
pas fait de l'image de paris pour une
culture des taxis de la brutalité jab et
eastgate a fait 1 et voilà dans le
conflit c'était entre eux mais ce que je
veux dire c'est qu'entre 20 entre lens
et contre la direction
en tout cas moi c'est ça de ma vie de ma
vision du karaté ce traitement là par
les médias qui est un peu étonnant mais
mais c'est vrai que le dialogue social
pour dire frange est ce que vous dites
c'est que dès lors qu'on est dans la
lutte des classes et qu'on n'est pas
dans la culture du compromis
il ya là des faux-nez problème
effectivement de blocage du dialogue
social 6 6 1 devant s'il y en a qu'un
seul qui fait un pas et pas l'autre
parlons du dialogue social ici pas crise
on demanderait de réaliser des jours et
des améliorations des conditions à la
rai non non non non pas peut-être allez
vous sortir avec votre veste en lambeaux
conflit ouvert avec la direction
félicité est ce que je peux vous
demander si la france est un pays de
rêve
ça m'intéressait quand j'entendis
saint-léger poser la question posée
pourquoi parler un peu de la raddho de
la fac et qui passent pas parce que noté
pas passionnant travail
elle est intéressante sur le plan
politique elle était intéressante
haussier sur ton médiatique à mon avis
mais
oui qu'est-ce qu'est ce quelle était
votre réaction sur le coup je me suis
dit que c'était impossible et c'est une
erreur quoi dire une chose aussi énorme
stis c'était vraiment absurde gt gt
complètement haute et la cité
j'étais gosse au mcee et en pensant à
tous ceux qui des dom-tom je me suis dit
mais il n'a pu pas dire une chose aussi
énorme
pourtant moi je viens d'afrique je suis
pas fermé de mes parents cela après que
tu né au cameroun
même si je suis française maintenant
mais ça je suis elle a oublié une frange
de la population qui est française
depuis des siècles sur tout ce qui est
quand même complètement fou c'est que la
notion de race est une notion purement
intellectuel culturel parce que la race
oui mais bon
non mais enfin il paraît non d'accord
non mais là tu vois ça un peu ridicule
et ciba si intellectuellement je pense
que m c'est chez les humains mais cela
mais elle parlait elle parlait soit que
c'était dans le cadre des problématiques
des migrants mais je suis désolé mais
les syriens ils ont la peau blanche
ils ont dit enfin un les irakiens les
iraniens les libanais les voilà je
préfère le défenseur de l'année morano
mais elle n'a pas elle avait a dit que
le vaisseau du holland tout à l'heure et
leur a dit que l'aah ce devait être un
pays de race blanche canadien le pays
la france est un pays et ça paraît
difficile de le nier
on peut regarder des photos du début du
siècle dernier les débuts de la
photographie
on aura du mal à montrer à trouver des
gens qui ne sont pas blancs en france ça
ne paraît pas être la ferrage intérêt
mais ça ne s'est pas question de
tergiverser question de réalité de dire
qu'il ya 150 ans la france était plutôt
un pays blanc il devra réagir et aux
chrétiens
voilà ne me paraît pas nié être une
mesure pour les gens qui n'ont pas la
peau blanche ni l'énormité après ses
essais est-ce que c'est là aussi mais je
reviens là dessus je dis que mes parents
sont camerounais
quand je suis né enfin avant que je
naisse mes parents étaient français il
était né au cameroun et le cameroun
avait des colonies
sans revient cent ans en arrière nous
avait des territoires où il y avait des
gens elle va lui l'air qui était sur
personne ni sam est majoritairement gay
tony
c'est pareil cas fin on ne peut pas dire
non plus que la france sur un pays
d'origine afin de d'origine est
d'habitude chrétienne par exemple on
peut pas le dire non plus parce que l'on
a croisé le dire nous plaît beaucoup
mais je vous avais dit cela c'est
indéniable
c'est par voie quand même plus de
cathédrale que d'autres monuments du
sultan france s'est ouvert sur scène
c'est la france qui était paris celles
qui refusaient de mettre les racines
judéo chrétiennes dans la constitution
européenne sont fermés mais ce que je
veux dire c'est que c'est pas parce que
une minorité de existe après on va me
dire il y avait des avis des musulmans
au xviiie siècle en france donc on veut
pas dire que la france aurait été non
c'est pas parce qu'il ya des gens qui
n'étaient pas chrétiens que ce que ça ça
veut dire que la france n'était pas
n'est pas d'origine chrétienne lorraine
et que dire de la jarrie terme ans dans
ce cas là mais s'est pas exprimée ainsi
qu'après que morano ce ne soit pas la
personne la plus délicate qu'il soit on
est tous d'accord
ah c'est sûr on est d'accord la table ce
que j'ai entendu sarkozy qui a dit mais
la france n'est pas une race mais ne l'a
pas des avants laurent ont été choqués
bien sûr j'ai été choqué par moi
personnellement oui j'ai été choqué même
si
culturellement il y as ddd petite partie
de la population enfin enfin tout le
monde sait on est insolent peuvent
finalement que ce soit des minorités ou
des majorités voilà on s'en estiment
tous français et voilà principal c'est
de s'estimer français après peu importe
d'où l'on vient et bonbons maintenant
quand christine taubira parle de race
créole personne ne crie personne ne dit
pas seulement voilà une boulette est
annoncé comme le ministre de la justice
el haddioui la race créole et elle est
bien la race crème très bien en plus il
ya un jugement de valeur parce que marc
ne l'a même pas 10 mai mme morano l'a
pas dit les blancs sont mieux armés
alors que miss de la justice et bien non
pas parce que c'est une chose qui est
aussi littéraire quoi c'est quelque
chose dont parlait aussi maryse condé et
c'est à la scélérate la tuque du moment
ça peut être mieux géré à ses couleurs
en créole ça n'est pas une couleur c'est
encore autre chose c'est une culture
c'est tout ce que je suis on peut le
dire non je peux tu devrais pas dire une
chose c'était pas le fait de s'abriter
derrière de bol ça m'a beaucoup amusé ça
va oui je ne sais pas c'est un peu
facile qui va elle même faisait reproche
à sarkozy d'avoir sorti la france du
contexte mais enfin c'est ce qu'elle a
fait aussi l égard elle même de la
sélection de vous rappeler qu'ils
étaient en 59
c'était en 59 et puis vous savez on se
on voit une des évolutions très forte le
terme négresse cacher quand vous
voyez qu'on trouve dans des dans des
bouquins pour enfants des années jusque
dans les années 1950 60 aujourd'hui il
est devenu inacceptable parce que
péjoratif raciste c'est la phrase de
jules ferry 10 885 les races supérieures
doivent s'imposer aux rares il ya même
les plus grands esprits dans le contexte
de leur temps à
on proférait des choses qui sont estimés
aujourd'hui comme étant inacceptable
mais c'est à cette affaire de race
blanche moi ça m'a choqué mais je me
suis demandé pourquoi ça me choque ali
et je fais et je me suis dit ce qu'on
perd de vue y compris dans les débats
que nous avons c'est et ça a été dit par
reparlera à l'instant c'est la
conception fins et je pense que c'est
l'un des auteurs qui a le mieux
manifester cette conception la de la
france et ernest renan qui pour résumer
les choses disait être français la
citoyenneté française
c'est le souvenir d'une culture alors le
souvenir d'un antique cimetière ça c'est
mitterand qui avait dit cela en parlant
justement de ernest renan moi je crois
que c'est c'est vraiment cela dans
l'esprit de 1789
cette universalité qui veut que être
français c'est adhérer à une espèce de
souvenirs de souvenirs au sens
historique et culturel du terme et
adhérer à un projet mais ça n'est que
cela ça veut dire que c'est un show
alors le problème avec la race je crois
pas que le débat soit soit inintéressant
il est problématique parce que on sait
que scientifiquement les races
n'existent pas y compris dans l'ordre
naturel mais on s'est dans le même temps
il suffit de lire l'article premier de
la constitution française pour voir que
le terme existent d'exister qu'il existe
dans plusieurs dizaines de textes
juridiques en matière pénale notamment
le terme même de reims il est aussi
paradoxalement un concept de combat
contre le racisme et contre les
discriminations
il y avait eu des propositions de
modifier de réviser l'article 20 de la
constitution qui prévoit le donc
l'égalité
des individus quelle que soit la gym etc
ça n'a pas pu être possible
techniquement mais il faudrait en effet
réfléchir à cela le le terme de race est
ambigu parce qu'il est infondée
scientifiquement mais juridiquement il a
une fonctionnalité qui quittent leurs
valets qui n'existe pas au débat dire
que ça n'existe pas alors il ya aussi
une autre nom sur le plan politique
quelque chose la réaction si yahia
pourquoi pourquoi on la sanctionne quand
même ça c'est intéressant
pourquoi tout d'un coup alors j'ai
l'impression qu'ils aient beaucoup de
gens qui disent des conneries que de
temps en temps il a qui passe au travers
des mailles et dans tant d'autres que
retient et elle elle fait partie de
sakho qu'ont en commun qu'on a pris de
relais dans le film dont il est victime
ce n'est pas d'un recentrage peut-être
de l'ardèche et quantité c'est avant
tout victime d'être une femme ait eu bat
à c'est une femme qui n'a pas fait l'ena
qui s'exprime dans un français qui était
plus proche de celui qu'utilise la
majorité de nos concitoyens que celui
qu'utilise le collège de france ça c'est
certain
alors du coup il ya un mépris très
facile de toutes les élites mot dire oui
on la traite les charcutiers apprécions
la traite de charcutière 2 ânières ge de
poissonnière faim qui touche on sort
comme ça un espèce de damas de gamme de
2 pour les ont qui sortent ces trucs là
ça va être une insulte d'être charcutier
j'imagine puisque on la traite de
vilaines charcutière et voilà élire là
ce n'est pas entendu une seule femme
une seule association dire ben m'sick un
peu gonflé traiter cette femme avec
autant de mépris quoi qu'elle dise non
là on s'en fout mais en gros pour
l'instant de l'adil morano c711 être sur
lequel on peut s'appuyer les pieds on
peut lui vomir dessus la traiter tous
les noms personne n'a la défense que ces
personnes pour grade l'égalité entre les
sexes alors accueillir un peu vincent
attend aussi une famine comme
et autant de caudry gommes secs
mégalithes arrive il ya peut-être ça
aussi non il ya peut-être un recentrage
afin de république enfin il ya non ça je
n'en sais pas je doute qu enfin
recentrage du côté du jubé évidemment
mais la ligne forte défendu par sarkozy
je ne pense pas qu'elle soit franchement
centriste et là ça s'appelle une grenade
dégoupillée pour sarkozy les racines
elle est lui aussi à essayer quand même
de la mi temps en juillet il ya une
autre dimension qui la dimension
médiatique c'est à dire que c'est rigolo
parce que vous connaissez un peu mais je
veux dire jamais on n'a autant parlé
d'elle je m'étais invité au 20 heures ou
21 est invitée au 20h
on ne parle que d'elle elle fait la une
des journaux et est-ce qu'il ya sans
doute chez z et dans sa robe stricte de
de ne pas revenir en arrière peut-être
ne s'est pas une sorte de
d'effervescence comme ça de 2 ce sont ce
sont 18 juin posé il ya près de
responsabilité là dessus les médias en
font leurs choux gras
parce que c'est bien c'est bien naturel
mais enfin souvenez vous il y avait eu
le bouquin de carlier sur n'a dit
seulement qu'il killer qui devrait dans
un premier temps couverte d'insultés
elle l'avait invité chez elle et sa
cette obligation d'un logement social
l'est de la france fille de camionneurs
machin et donc ils en avaient déduit que
c'était une personne forme de la gallia
de regret d'ailleurs il ya des ya
probablement des filles de camionneurs
qui vivent dans des logements sociaux
qui sont des personnes assez basse de
plafond enfin je regrette bien voilà
enfin peu importe s'est passé parce
qu'il est important que ce soit une
femme qu'elle soit d'origine modeste et
qu'elle s'exprime mal là n'est pas la
question
sarkozy n'a pas fait l'ena il n'est pas
d'origine modeste il est pas fils de
camionneurs enfin il dit aussi pas mal
de bêtises et puis là tout autour de lui
aussi mais je pense pas que cette ce
paramètre là entre vraiment en
considération
mon chat c'est pour ça que tout le monde
se jette sur cette pauvre femme
voilà alors peut-être écrire à l'ouvragé
non j'ai une grande nouvelle pour
terminer tous les tweets ce nom avec un
dessin je pense qu'on n'a pas retrouvé
on parle trop et c'est vrai que c'est
vrai que dès que vous dites que tout le
monde tout le monde le nom magie à votre
secours juste ajouter une chose alors
c'est pas un peu parallèle mais on
reproche sans s'arrêter aux hommes
politiques d'avoir un discours
complètement creux et sans intérêt et
dès qu'un homme politique
alors là je reconnais que c'est ça ça
prête à polémique scolaire mais dès
qu'un homme politique dit quelque chose
tout le monde lui tombe dessus
donc le plus ça va ya aucune possibilité
par un homme politique d'avoir un
discours autre que creuse mais non c'est
terminé limites comme non mais oui je
pense que j'en aurais aimé c'est sa
maman placer le curseur placé en hauteur
radio c'est tellement près que tu as n'y
a pas de marge de manoeuvre en homme
politique et regarder toutes les
optiques à droite comme à gauche une
liste de rien les discours sont d'un
creux mais c'était absolument or il n'y
a pas d'idée il ya pas mal parce qu'ils
sont persuadés ils savent très bien que
de façon devant se faire allumer dans
une partie par lou donc ne nous étonnera
c'est maintenant la place de politiques
certaines parole qui s'est libérée mais
une serveuse des couples ex des congrès
à trois ou quatre abouti peut-être mais
en règle générale les uns politique de
premier plan à gauche ou droit ne disent
absolument plus rien ne vient qu plus
qu'une
ça dépend presque dire ça c'est votre
ami m'a proposé de l'impact les gens
disent bord de votre pensant fou dont
elle allait vous dire ça changera rien
bah oui ils ont une même discours est ce
qui est en revanche la une alors que
j'ai trouvé extrêmement choquant c'est
là une de charlie hebdo sur cette
affaire j'ai trouvé utoya avec la faute
grave au dessin de
général de gaulle avec nadine morano
dans les bras 10 ans l'enfant trisomique
cacher ses comptes s'est entraînée
d'ailleurs la plainte d'une mère de
famille oui j'ai une grande nouvelle à
vous annoncer
c'est que françois bayrou était à
versailles on va l'écouter on a parlé
d'histoire on a parlé de de mon ami
henri iv on a parlé de ce qui s'est
passé avec les guerres de religion on a
parlé d' identité on a parlé du château
de versailles
on a parlé de l'europe et de la
construction de l'europe et de la vente
sûrs de ce qu'ils avaient construit
l'europe voilà et donc c'est c'est là
qu'on voit que entre l'histoire et la
politique n'y a pas de différence
la politique c'est de l'histoire au
présent et là pour les régionales bonne
question est ce qu'il ya une différence
entre l histoire et la politique vous
avez vous avez cinq minutes un peu
perdus n'ont pas parler un peu des
élections régionales puisque là il ya
pendant longtemps c'était très serré
entre venez les pécresse et et claude
bartolone et puis là des sondages qui
semble dire que finalement valérie
pécresse se détache y en plus une
affaire qui risque de gros plans fictifs
qui risque de gêner le président de
l'assemblée nationale
est-ce que vous pensez que ces jouets
c'est à dire belgique apparaît sa part
un peu cuit pour la pour la gauche mais
premier tour
c'était un retournement basculement ce
que c'est un peu aussi le défaut de tous
ces sondages
tellement en triomphant pour un coût un
côté ou l'autre c'est que après sa mort
me lisent une correction attise les
haines et de son envie de voter à gauche
s'ils lisent leur journal tous les
matins ils regardent le sondage
catastrophe en avait pas intention d'y
aller on va peut-être y aller voilà ça
peut se corriger quand même et ça peut
faire peur ça peut mais est ce que c est
ce que c'est une campagne qui intéresse
quelqu'un s'est senti l'impression que
par les autres qui se présente c'est sa
fille cadette le jour de l'élection puis
surtout que ça vient après les élections
départementales qui n'entraîne plus
historique pour la gauche et les foules
en plus c'est l'un des camps oui bien
sûr mais les élections régionales par
par tradition c'est pas un scrutin très
mobilisateur alors que c'est le scrutin
qui peut réserver en général le presque
les plus grande surprise au regard de de
son caractère très favorable pour les
petits petit article is no need marty et
c'est alors des petits qui sont devenus
grands comme le front national mais on
aurait tort de s'en désintéresser
parce que les conseils régionaux ont de
plus en plus de compétences ont de plus
en plus de pouvoir et au sur le simple
plan du jeu politique
il peut en effet y avoir des surprises
et des événements totalement inattendue
ça vous intéresse
moi ça m'intéresse pour le grand paris
savoir règle c'est cette perspective là
de transport et d'offre de transport en
commun qu'est ce qui va finalement
découlé
c'est la seconde à moi qui me et la
campagne vous intéresse
est ce qu'on parle de ça justement dans
cette campagne électorale parce que
c'est pas très bien de quoi parle des
candidats étaient non voit poindre par
contre pas mal de bouquins de différents
candidats
ouais donc voilà c'est comme ça que nous
on vit ah oui c'est vrai c'est ça oui on
va arriver les livres les 1 1 3 2 août
on avait d'ailleurs dans le parisien la
nasa offrait des vrais chiffres de vente
des livres politiques
c'était catastrophique enfin dans le
fion marche bien visiblement le jubé
marche bien j'ai juppé marche bien le de
villiers aussi voilà dévié par oui mais
on livre politique voilà mais je paie
marche bien
oui après la surprise c'est que les
filles ont fait quasiment deux fois plus
que juppé parce que ce que personne
n'aurait parié un kopeck celui de mars
2005 pour occuper je prends donc ce
qu'est ce que tout ce qu'ils ont fait
beaucoup pour des rives de six ans et là
on sera valable côtoie celui de
moscovici je crois annoncé à 462
exemplaires ce qui fait que certains ont
dit voilà en sciences ou moins combien
également au ps
non pas parce qu ici cambadélis on va
bien les normands 18e
c'est là qu'on voit à la fois qu'il ya
peu de gens qui les fuit mais qui a peu
de valeur partie surtout parce que
généralement on est quand même obligé
d'acheter de lebouc a dû sous le
contrôle de laurent jeu on méprise
toujours un peu c'est un petit bonhomme
c'est ridicule
christine boutin quand même plus de
trente trois amis mais je pense que des
33 amie christine boutin et par
christine boutin ils ont acheté des
bouquins directement chez l'approché
l'éditeur ce qui n'est pas comptabilisé
dans les livres donc il ya peut-être 600
personnes où 2000 personnes qui ont
acheté le bouquin de christine boutin
mais en passant en passe
m d'acheter le livre fait qu'ils ont
précisé après il ya peut-être 2010 avec
qui on verra car comme cadeau mais la
france a pas le dire est que quand ça
passe pas par les libraires c'est pas
comptabilisés dans les chiffres et les
entrailles de ce crime racial qui
achètent par exemple livre de fillon il
ya pas d'archétypes non non non vraiment
on accueille sa forme et non enfin sur
fion si vraiment où je peux enfin alors
plutôt de droite si fins il ya qu'on
arrive un peu à cibler quoi puis les
gens qui disent un peu à gauche aussi
mais voilà enfin c'est des fois on a
étonné par les gens quoi voilà qui
lisent aussi du lait mouret et qui
achètent de 12,1 à la fabrique où enfin
voilà des gens qui ont envie de voir
d'autres choses des fois donc on défend
nous étonner mais très déçu de cette
ville de fillion alors ce qu'on peut
penser ne pouvant pas être trompée c'est
vrai qu'il ya un effort programmatique
oui un vrai forum roulait donc c'est
plutôt ration gens du thatchérisme
enfin vous verrez ça ne manque pas de
crise qui n'est pas nous voir le clergé
je pense à l'après facile ça fait 5 % en
france on attend chaque c'est le sol qui
est un programme parce que tous les
autres se disent faits sont là pas
besoin de programmes puisque la seule
idée c'est d'être d'arriver au deuxième
tour parce que même un âne sera élu
flamand il repérait n'a pas dit alors
que fillon commis rame un peu dans les
sondages que le terrain il a vraiment
besoin d'un truc d'un programme parce
que lui il peut pas pour l'instant rêver
du deuxième tour
donc pour arriver en tête ils étaient
forcés de mouiller la chemise et de
réfléchir un peu ce qui est plutôt bien
vu vous avez vu ce que jacques attali
eux a dit jacques a dit qu'au mieux ce
sera voilà c'est pour ça que
merci merci à tous les sacs les bestiaux
était bien on se retrouve très vite pour
un prochain paf